support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy so in the previous video from the
cathode ray tube experiment by JD
Thompson
he concluded that atoms have small
negatively charged particles inside of
them right that we called electrons and
of course that that disproved Dalton's
idea that atoms were indivisible
indivisible because if there's something
that's smaller than part is smart of it
then be smaller than atoms then then
atoms cannot be indivisible right
another thing that's important is to
recognize ok we know that electrons
themselves are negative but the overall
atom is neutral right so if that's the
case if the electrons are in the atom
and the atom is overall Natur that must
mean that there's a positive charge in
the atom to balance things out so this
is why Thomson came up with the plum
pudding model at the item now the plum
pudding is a British thing we don't
really hear much about that much in the
States at least I have it and I actually
googled a picture of it and I encourage
you to do so too it kind of looks like a
cake that is filled with raisins right
so just imagine that you have raisins in
a bunch of dough
some people think about like muffins
right how they have they have like
chocolate chips in them or or or
blueberries or whatever but the point is
it's some sort of dough that has little
pieces of whatever in it right so in the
case of the plum pudding atom or the
plum pudding model of the atom the
electrons are kind of are like the
raisins and then the dough is a
positively charged space so this is
little red things here of course are the
electrons it's for the electrons all
right that would be the the plums or the
raisins
and the rest of the space contains the
atom that little it's just a bunch of
fluffy dough that stuff is that dough is
positively charged so I'll kind of put a
plus charge here just a gigantic plus
that's dispersed through the atom so
that dough is basically positively
charged fluff or positively charged
dough or dough right so that's what
Thompson thought the atom looked like
because he discovered these electrons
you thought okay they're definitely
electrons our particular particles
inside of atoms but he wasn't really
sure about the rest of it and he thought
okay maybe there is just the space in
between them has this positively charged
fluff or dough that makes up this atom
okay so that's basically the plum
pudding model of the atom I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful be sure
to LIKE and subscribe for more content
also follow move university on the
different social media links in the
description below thank you and happy
studying